short time ago the fbi announced a major  arrest in  a six-year global investigation that  started here in las vegas  six people are accused of drug  trafficking and money laundering  according to special agent aaron rouse  there were seven  countries involved in this probe and  arrest  this operation should serve as a warning  to other criminal organizations  that regardless of where they operate  the fbi  and our outstanding law enforcement  partners around the world will root them  out  and bring them to justice the fbi says  this was a successful partnership to  fight organized crime  and there's more arrests to come